One of the major diseases of mismatch is obesity and obesity.
As we've seen earlier.
When we discussed what is the disease is a disease of homeostasis.
Basically it results from too much food and too little exercise.
It also has to do with food quality with sleep deprivation and the role that
Ghrelin hormone plays in mediating the effects of sleep deprivation.
There are effects of breastfeeding and of c-sections on the risk of obesity and
also having an abnormal weight early in life can change the risk of obesity as
an adult.
So it's a condition that has many causes.
Yeah.
The definition of someone is obese is anyone with a body mass index greater than
to put that in context,
in 1900 the average body mass mass index of American men between 40 and 60 was
23 by 2000 it was 27.5 in 2008 more than 15% of us adolescence,
we're obese.
Obesity is a major global health issue.
Mismatch now is contributing to obesity through energy balance,
through food quality,
through changes in sleep,
changes in our microbiota that results from less breastfeeding and more Securian
deliveries and under and over nourishment of infants and children.
So first energy balance.
Basically that is the product of too much food and too little exercise.
So the image on the left is a group of people who were hunter gatherers and the
late 19th century.
On the right there is an office worker in the late 19th century,
early 20th century.
Uh,
that is a shift from an active foraging lifestyle to a sedentary lifestyle.
The physical activity level is defined as the total daily energy output divided
by the basal metabolic rate.
In hunter gatherers,
it's about 1.85 in farmers is about 1.78 to 1.8599999999999999 so farmers can be
working just as hard as hunter gatherers and office workers.
It's about 1.512 1.6099999999999999 what that means is that if a hunter gatherer
farmer changes to the lifestyle of an office worker while continuing to eat the
3000 calories a day that he used to need,
then he will have an energy surplus of about 450 calories a day.
That's enough to make him rapidly obese.
Yeah.
If we look at food quality and compare the diets of hunter gatherers with
average Americans and with the US recommended daily allowance,
basically what we see is that hunter gatherers had less carbohydrate,
less sugar,
less fat and less sodium,
and that our food quality compared to a hunter gatherers has less protein,
fiber,
vitamin C and D and potassium
hunter gatherers.
We're actually getting a reasonable amount of fat in their diet,
but it was less saturated fat.
They had considerably more fiber in their diet than we do and they were getting
a lot more potassium and a lot less sodium.
These are all things that are feeding into mismatch diseases.
Okay,
so if we have a lot of refined starch and sugar in our diet,
then we get a spike in blood sugar that results from simple starches that
stimulates the pancreas to produce insulin that causes blood sugar to be taken
up by muscle and fat cells.
There is now so much sugar and starch and our dye that the spike is unnatural
and stimulates too much insulin and that causes blood sugar then to crash.
We then get hungry and we overeat and that will not occur if we were eating
complex starches and sugars that were associated with fiber.
So refined starches and simple sugars result in an overproduction of insulin and
that causes blood sugar to crash and that makes us hungry again much sooner than
we should be.
Another thing that influences our appetite is sleep deprivation and Graylin.
Here are two to deprive men passing out on a park bench.
Hunter Gatherers get eight to nine hours of sleep at night and they take a two
hour nap in the afternoon,
so they are actually getting nearly an average of 10 hours of sleep a day.
Modern American sleep,
six to seven hours at night and only a third of them take naps.
So that's the asleep deficit of somewhere in the neighborhood of three to four
hours per day.
Yeah.
Sleep deprivation reduces cell repair.
It cuts down on immune function and it increases cortisol which raises blood
sugar if high levels of cortisol persist,
they depressed immune function in the increased the risk of type two diabetes.
Sleep deprivation causes the levels of Leptin which inhibits appetite to fall
and the levels of Ghrelin which stimulates appetite to rise,
sleep deprived,
deprived people are therefore hungry and they crave carbohydrates
so our bodies interprets sleep deprivation is a stress the needs to be with
increased food intake and it is no longer reliably associated with the kinds of
stress that needs increased food intake.
There are two other important cultural innovations that have gone on.
One is that there is less breastfeeding and the second is that there are more
c-sections.
One study found that breastfed babies were 13 pounds lighter at 14 years of age
and babies that have been fed formula breast milk contains illegal saccharides
that stimulate the growth of beneficial bacteria and infant guts.
So some of this may be mediated by the establishment of a gut flora that can
mediate this uptake of energy.
A study of 1,255 children in Boston found that birth by csection doubles the
risk of obesity at age three compared to a vaginal birth.
The intestinal Microbiota of infants that are born by csection resembles that of
maternal skin,
not that of maternal vagina and anus.
Okay.
Another effect is abnormal weight.
Early in life,
as we've seen earlier with our discussion of the Dutch hunger,
hunger winter,
the nutritional status of fetus in Utero and of infants and young children
produces a delayed effect on the risk of adult disease.
This is the doe had or developmental origins of health and disease framework.
Okay.
Under nursing,
infants and children have a greater risk of obesity,
diabetes,
cardiovascular disease,
and hypertension is adults that didn't.
This is caused by insulin resistance.
This might be a predictive adaptive response that anticipates future few food
shortage,
or it might be designed to protect infant brain during development.
We can't really be sure which of those is the correct explanation.
Yeah.
Children who are overweight also have increased risk of obesity as adults.
So if you're too thin or if you're too heavy as a child,
you have increased risk of obesity.
The expansion of the visceral fat mass may change appetite and body weight set
points and perpetuate over overeating because persistent high levels of Leptin
Produce Leptin resistance and that produces increased appetite and decreased
energy expenditure.
So to summarize,
the causes of obesity are many.
The treatments are numerous.
People become obese because they eat too much and exercise too little.
They eat processed food that produce insulin spikes.
They have particular genes,
they are sleep deprived and produced more Graylin.
Their microbiota had been disturbed by infant formula or by c section,
or they were over or under nourished his children.
So it is a multifactorial causal chain,
but it is producing one of the major epidemics that currently threatened the
health of contemporary populations.